well hello there reject nation I'm Greg
I'm John today is a video request from a
monthly this is one of our monthly
videos yeah gene Jeter request this is
just a heart symbol two of them double
the heart it's triple the fun guys if
you haven't seen any gene Jeter videos
well you got out of you two things one
find the nearest window on a second or
third story building or house or
apartment building jump out of it
or to save your life everything about
your life by going to the gene Jeter
YouTube channel let's watch this
I heard he just had these chicks
improvise and he made a short film out
of it seems like a thing that you
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
improv comedy imagination
she has a key in her ear well but each
what by falling in love it might be
although this is like thriller music not
just a gene Jeter's version of romance
just try not to get how do I say I've
changed the beat on this what is
happening you're skipping it's visual
story love your elusive esoteric type of
filmmaking so Lucy I don't know hang
those words mean by the way they just
sound big I like this shot then
I think gene has his own genre and I'm
gonna call it gene wave I like this it's
gonna end with her being two cabs here
down there yeah I wonder if they just
happened upon this sir
see they're falling in love oh she was
just fantasizing it the whole time but
never actually went through with it oh
that's messed up Jean
I was invested would you do that so the
whole journey I was watching gene Media
Jeannie dia Jeannie dia Geneva Geneva
pictures media that moving picture you
can have that us that's for you
copyright that hey hey this is charming
I liked it I did too I don't know if you
heard me say this but it's lucid yes
teri jeans joints have a tendency to
like need to draw you in a little bit
you need to kind of spend a few moments
going what is happening here and then
you start to kind of grasp what's going
on and then you know and yeah eventually
things get conceptual and then you're
just kind of feeling the mood I did like
the overall wrap around that idea of
sitting down next to someone and that
feeling of yeah maybe I should strike up
a conversation you lost your own
imagination but you wait too long to act
before you know what the opportunity
passes you up I tell you I've been way
too many situations or I spent so much
time fantasizing and then when the
moment comes for me to do it this one
opportunity I do not lose myself in the
music yeah I think the actresses were
pretty good too they felt very natural
they'd had their chemistry on the right
level and I also thought that for them
improvising pretty good there's some
improvised lines that just sound like
improv
whole thing about the duck yeah that's a
very like improv comedy joke there's
people like right over there it's not
what you said it is not a real life I
think the audience is really missing
from some of his short films is just
better sound mixing like sure we can
Nipigon on terms of like lighting and
whatever overall I'm like well if you
just had smoother sound yeah in your
scenes and cuts and stuff it would
literally make the whole thing that much
of a higher quality yeah everything
would just feel smooth because sometimes
yeah it calls attention to things like
cuts and that one camera shutter sound
effect was kind of jarring because of
how loud it is in the mix yeah just that
one element cuz I got the sense the Jean
probably goes out with his talent or
whoever and does these things very
on-the-fly that's the impression that I
get and so yeah maybe just some kind of
attachment Mike to consistent less than
that moment cuz I kind of like the way
the shutter had a cut to it me certainly
felt like it was becoming a horror movie
all the time but the cuts that I really
I'm talking about or like when they're
the middle of a conversation and then it
cuts to a close-up
yeah and it's obviously a completely
different take it doesn't feel it's
hardly the same well yeah there's the
lack of a flow because of like okay the
audio sounds very different here in the
background and like having that
background audio is very important to
smoothing out these scenes which are
always a [ __ ] to deal with because you
know it's like if you watch am our
sketch is ooh that's always a really
difficult thing to it to figure out but
enough to where we try to make it not
distracting I mean other than that
that's really the only thing you know
when I come to a Jean Jeter joint or to
Boeing and what is this weirdness I'm
watching and you're becoming like on my
own little couldn't turn T know of like
diving into the psychology of your mind
you remind me like a young Cronenberg or
like a young Cronenberg meets a young
David Fincher especially with your like
Trent Reznor kind of music you like to
put in here when it's not a horror scene
but it always feels like it that's the
vibe I you know there's buddy there's
like a percolating dread but it's also
this one in particular is very kind of
sweet and bitter sweet yes yeah is
Quentin Tarantino over here it's
engineer yo hey that's where that rolls
right off
right right and does like Keanu Jeeves
hey ass Jeeves what to watch probably
gene Hackman
oh that's just enactment gene Davis
oh yeah gene Jeter Davis gene Jade right
that works like the pants yeah jeans GJ
JEA Jean Grey yeah
jean reno she want to trample on that
name crunch his name [ __ ] jean jury no
ginger Reno who's that
that's jean Reno oh but Derek Jeter yeah
that's just Derek Jeter spent a minute
is this yeah we could split what we
should do is we're all these names we
should splice the celebrity with genes
that's a lot one of those baby fun oz
it's a lot of unnecessary work I'm gonna
do Majan it in your I trust the audience
can use their own imagination that we
don't have to show them everything you
know what gene looks like as the
customer is always right subscribe to
gene Jeter's YouTube channel he's got
all kinds of things
erotic modeling shoots but she wouldn't
call erotic cause he's a [ __ ]
professional hahahaha also these guys
short films yes and also some strange
try not to laughs he did one doe is try
not to something weird trying to get
aroused or something oh my what if like
it was like I'm no that couldn't have
been it anyway go check out his YouTube
channel is weird
try not to feel existential despair